after a dozen years of legal fights
seven years in the crosshairs of
ambitious prosecutors and 5 and a half
years of a federal case that saw his
company forcibly shut down his bank
accounts Frozen his ankle monitored and
his longtime partner commits suicide
Michael Lacy the alt weekly newspaper
impressario has at long last been found
guilty of exactly one of the 86 criminal
charges levied against him in connection
with the online advertising platform
back page but if you think the
government's antical pursuit of lacy and
four other Backpage codefendants is over
then like almost every journalist in
this country you haven't been following
one of the biggest Free Speech trials in
modern history Lacy an award-winning
investigative journalist was found
guilty of international concealment
money laundering which could land him in
prison for up to 20 years and he was
also found not guilty on another count
but the jury after a week of
deliberation could not come to agreement
on the other 84 charges prompting judge
Diane Huma to to declare a second
mistrial in this case so yes Mike Lacy
might be forced to stand trial for a
third time essentially for the crime of
running a classified ads company that
knowingly enabled and profited from
illegal if consensual transactions
involving sex normally the speech and
conduct of users in the comment sections
of websites is considered to be the
legal responsibility of the speakers
themselves and not the owners of the
platform that was built into section 230
of the 1996 Communications deal decency
act known by its admirers as the
internet's First Amendment but back page
in particular has been the tip of the
federal spear in forcing those online
freedoms back kamla Harris and 46 other
State Attorneys General just over a
decade ago sent a joint letter to
Congress urging the roll back of section
230 here's how that letter began every
day children in the United States are
sold for sex in instance after instance
state and local authorities discover
that the vehicle vehicles for
advertising the victims of the child sex
trade to the world are online classified
ad services such as backpage.com it's
here I should point out that at no point
in all the various prosecutions of
Backpage has the company ever been
formally accused of contributing to the
child's sex trade in fact that's why the
first case in 2021 ended in a mistrial
prosecutors refused to stop using the
lurid sounding phrase sex trafficking
just 7 weeks before her election to the
Senate Harris along with their Texas
counterpart Ken Paxton brought the first
case against Mike Lacy his partner Jim
Lin and other Executives at back page
putting the senior citizen defendants in
orange jumpsuits in a courtroom cage in
Sacramento as if they might otherwise Go
full Hannibal Lector on innocent
bystanders that case was tossed out by a
judge who pointed out Congress did not
wish to hold liable online Publishers
for the action of publishing third party
speech it is for congress not this court
to revisit no matter 3 days before
leaving the AG's office for the Senate
Harris filed yet another case against
back page for pimping and money
laundering the pimping charge was
promptly thrown out because of section
230 once in Congress meanwhile Harris
helped push through the fight online sex
trafficking act or fosta that indeed
peels back section 230 to make websites
liable for the facilitation or promotion
of prostitution by their users even
though prostitution itself is not a
federal crime this latest trial did not
rely on fosta but also the defense was
barred by the judge from even bringing
up section 230 on grounds that it's
somehow only applicable to State crimes
prostitution between consenting adults
should be legal straight up but even if
you believe the opposite is true the
persecution of Backpage has been a
disaster back when the company was still
around the federal government praised it
repeatedly for assisting law enforcement
in identifying sex traffickers and other
criminals now that it's gone on
according to the government
accountability office the FBI's ability
to identify victims and sex traffickers
has decreased significantly in the
meantime Publishers of any kind of
website that features user generated
content are considerably more vulnerable
to being held criminally liable for the
conduct of their customers those are the
kinds of free speech Stakes that news
organizations used to care about yet the
Backpage trial got barely any national
coverage or attention people's brains
shut off when you scare them about child
sex trafficking in the internet
regardless of whether there's any
evidence and too often those who are
supposed to be skeptical of power become
differential when it's politicians
making the Fantastical accusations two
of the Backpage defendants were
convicted on dozens of counts and could
face life in prison but even the two
defendants who were exonerated said
their lives have been quote ruined Mike
Lacy's partner friend and codefendant
committed suicide rather than subject
himself and his family to more pain all
of this is being done in your name using
your tax dollars in a process that has
made you less free journalists no longer
seem to care about this will
you